Some big guys sitting over there waiting for you, you said you don't know who he is you
Ukrainian boxer victor drago appear today in Philadelphia
Bringing back Ivan Drago and his son Victor in that history that animosity it just made it more intense
This is Creed vers Drago
This is the fight. The whole world wants to see unless he's afraid of history repeat itself
Rocky's past has caught up to him because the darkest moment in Rocky's life is when Apollo Creed's substituted for him
It's a fight Drago and he died
And so now the donnas Creed feels like he should avenge. His father ain't got a choice
that's the same thing your father said and he died right here in my hands Ivan Drago is the iconic character for
Destroying one of our other iconic air does Apollo Creed?
So it was really cool to revive him in a way that felt fresh and new because of you
I lose everything Yvan was a Olympic champion. He was a hero of the Soviet Union but 33 years ago
He lost a fight with the Jew Rocky Balboa
So now he's trying to turn his life around using his son as the vehicle for him to come back onto the world stage
perhaps
Because of the history it's easy to make this match up
So this is his big chance and it's not about treats about him and his father having break you to money
You know the stakes it's a loaded situation
These dudes killed my pops
I can't let that slide the ciock laid out in a new generation with a new I go in the new create
It was fantastic. This is our chance to rewrite history